de la realidad vivida por muchas personas,
y que esta realidad se extiende hasta el lugar de trabajo.
Ya sea en tecnología o finanzas, deportes o la industria de servicios,
todos los días escuchamos otra historia sobre un abuso de poder
u otro comportamiento laboral inapropiado.
La gente está furiosa.
Están tomando Twitter y las redes sociales para expresar que esto debe cambiar.
Pero es hora de ir más allá del hashtag.
Es hora de que denunciemos el acoso y la discriminación
ante aquellos que pueden arreglar este lío.
Y es hora de que hablemos de acoso.
De una manera más inclusiva:
no solo sobre el acoso sexual,
sino para animar a la gente a que dé a conocer
el acoso y la discriminación en función de otras características
tales como la edad, discapacidad o etnia.
Porque solo juntos podemos arreglar
las causas subyacentes y las consecuencias del acoso.
La mayoría de nosotros experimentaremos
en algún momento de nuestras vidas,
acoso o discriminación laboral.
La investigación muestra que en especial las mujeres, las personas de color y
personas que se identifican abiertamente como LGBTQI probablemente serán atacadas,
y para algunas, esta es una parte generalizada y persistente de su realidad.
Y para la mayoría de estas personas,
el 98 % según algunos estudios,
la mayoría de estas personas nunca hablarán o se lo dirán a su empleador.
Con mucha frecuencia, el acoso y la discriminación
son una experiencia solitaria y aislada,
pero debemos ayudar a la gente a salir de debajo de sus escritorios.
Necesitamos empoderar a las personas para que tengan una voz.
La primera pregunta razonable que todos hacen